le 78 du 6 décembre consacré en grande
partie au télét on parle notamment des
animations et puis pour compléter ce que
nous disions tout à l'heure sachez que
les villes sont donc mobilisées les
salles de concert également c'est le cas
de la batterie AG guuill en cours
concert prévu le 7 décembre avec une
soirée scène française soma volo ben Mau
ce sont trois groupes français qui vont
se produire pour des places entre eux
5,50 et 6,50 € et puis bien sûr ce sera
reversé intégralement au Téléton plus
d'informations sur la batterie de guuill
encour.fr j'accueille à présent Richard
com bonsoir secrétaire général de RVVS
la radio locale yvelinoise radio valde
scè ODIL modué bonsoir de Mani Lamo vous
êtes la mère d'un enfant atteint par
donc une une des maladies concernées
lors du Téléton on écoutera tout à
l'heure votre témoignage et son
témoignage aussi nous sommes allés le
rencontrer Richard combe 26h d'antenne
200 km 20 animateurs mobilisés sont
quelques chiffres comme ça pour montrer
que l'ampleur de de de la manifestation
pour votre radio oui en fait on a on a
on a décidé il y a une dizaine d'années
de ne plus faire le Téléton à
l'intérieur d'un studio en passant des
coups de film même si c'était déjà plein
d'émotions et et plein de rencontre
intéressante on a décidé de sortir et
puis on s'est dit il y a pas de raison
c'est pas parce qu'on a une radio
associative qu'on peut pas mettre une
régie dans un camion et puis se brancher
sur des lignes téléphonique partout dans
dans les ivelines et donc on a décidé de
le faire et maintenant on fait
effectivement ce trajet 13 villes 13 à
15 villes à peu près qu'on couvre entre
le vendredi 19h et le Samedi 22h en
direct 45 minutes dans chaque ville vous
vous lez relayez quand même tr animateur
non c'est vous en fait voilà il y a 45
minutes dans la ville ensuite le studio
prend le relais nous on on range tout on
fait le trajet on ressort tout et
pendant ce temps-là à l'antenne il y a
des magazines des journaux des
chroniques toujours autour du Téléton de
la musique puis on essaie de s'amuser
aussi beaucoup pour que les gens aent
envie de continuer avec nous jusqu'à 3 4
5h du matin et pourquoi pas faire le
tour de l'horloge complet vous nous
disiez c'est mieux d'aller sur le
terrain pour faire vivre justement cette
manifestation comment vous êtes
accueilliis sur place comment vous la
faites vivre aussi parce que c'est de la
radio il y a pas l'image aussi donc
c'est un important voilà alors en fait
le meilleur moyen pour faire vivre une
manifestation c'est de jouer le jeu et
donc en fait nous on s'est arrangé
maintenant pour avoir des micros
serre-tête et des micros voilà qu'on a
pas dans les mains pour pouvoir
justement tout faire tes acteur voilà
quand il y a du vélo on fait du vélo
quand c'est à la piscine on met le
maillot quand il faut courir on court et
en fait effectivement on essaie de vivre
de l'intérieur ce qui se passe sur les
manifestations et puis surtout notre
boulot c'est vraiment de tendre le micro
à tous ceux qui sont là les
organisateurs évidemment mais aussi les
familles on a beaucoup de de parents et
de de d'enfants malades qui sont sur les
manifestations émerveillés par le monde
qui est là et leur tendre le micro c'est
aussi leur donner la parole ce jour-là
et comme on fait pas assez le reste du
temps et ben voilà c'est le jour où il
faut vraiment tendre ce micro et depuis
quand vous êtes mobilisé sur
RVVS pratiquement depuis le début au
départ c'était juste une émission le
samedi qui durait 1 heure et où on
passait quelques coups de fil mais dans
cette version là où avec un camion on
fait le tour de la région ça fait une
dizaine d'années une dizaine d'années
depuis une dizaineanné dizaine d'années
pardon quel est le souvenir qui vous a
le plus marqué vous retenez est-ce qu'
il y a des choses qui vous ont marqué
forcément puisque vous allez rencontrer
les gens vous écoutez les familles aussi
oui il y a il y a beaucoup de rencontres
qu'on a fait à la Saint-Louis de poissie
il y a quelques années on avait
rencontré une maman qui alors qu'il y
avait des fanfares autour de nous avait
créé une petite bulle autour d'elle et
on était tous les deux face- à face
j'avais le casque sur la tête on
entendait plus la fanfare elle me
racontait la vie de de de son enfant et
c'était voilà c'était juste poignant et
et vraiment plein d'espoir puis y a
aussi plein de moments drôle évidemment
avec des des
des énormes jeux de mots totalement
inattendus parce qu'au bout de 22hur
d'antenne on sait plus très bien ce
qu'on dit et du coup voilà les les
coordinateurs des Yveline West que je
salue Jean-Jacques deésierre et toute
son équipe on voilà beaucoup de plaisir
toujours à me rappeler mes gaffes et
voilà j'espère en faire plein cette
année et ça va vous on a écouter RVVS
pour pour en savoir plus on rappelle la
fréquence 96 2 c'est ça voilà je me
trompe pas pour cette pour cette radio
mobilisé vous pensez quoi de cette
opération c'est parfait très bien c'est
très bien de faire faire ce genre de
chos ça peut toujours apporter plein de
choses aux gens et puis ça leur fait
plaisir en même temps puis vous vous
amusez c'est une grosse organisation
technique aussi il y a des partenaires
pour monter tout ça pour une radio
associative comment vous fa pour part
rien que les camions les camions c'est
du prê évidemment on a une société qui
nous prête un camion la mairie des Murau
où notre studio est installé participe
également et puis après bah c'estes 50
bénévoles de la radio qui chacun avec
leurs compétences font ce qu'il faut
pour que pour qu'on soit à l'antenne
alors voilà parfois on nous entend plus
parfois on nous entend trop mais en tout
cas c'est fait avec beaucoup de beaucoup
de cœur et voilà on est heureux d'aller
à la rencontre des gens qui ont besoin
de parler parce que c'est vraiment
extrêmement important de pouvoir
s'exprimer régulièrement sur sur la
maladie sur ce qu'on vit c'est aussi une
manière de de prendre une respiration
pour la suite